[Music]
danny's in syracuse hi danny welcome to
the ramsay show
hi dave uh i've enjoyed your practical
advice over the past few years and i
would like a little bit of your insight
into comprising a will okay
specifically
will basically has several beneficiaries
most of them or all of them rather are
financially responsible except for one
very irresponsible the only thing
they've learned is to use a credit card
have dad come in and pay it
that's a recipe for collecting the
inheritance and starting the fast clock
from 700 000 that broke
so
i've heard you suggested on your show
about financial peace or diversity as a
requirement
uh how could that be done
and specifically
with the entire course is there like a
practical way on having it be an ongoing
participation making that a requirement
well yeah you can just take them out of
the will until they behave
yeah you sound like you have to put it
leave them in there why you have to
leave them in there you don't
no i i don't yeah okay let's start with
here's the thing an inheritance is not
an entitlement you are not entitled to
an inheritance
you are not obligated morally ethically
biblically to leave your money to anyone
in particular
now in our house we're people of faith
and to
mismanage
your life
meaning
the steward the management of your life
including your money um is you know
you're supposed to be managing your life
for god you're managing your life as as
christians we're gonna manage god's
money and if you can't manage god's
money i'm i'm
duty-bound to not give it to you to
mismanage from my perspective as a
steward number one but number two it's
not going to be a blessing to this
person it's they're gonna it's gonna
bring them harm because when you get
money it it
magnifies the good and the bad in your
life so it's not about financial peace
university and it's not about being a
control freak it's about putting your
arm around this this child and saying
um
gosh
i don't want to hurt you
i love you too much to hurt you and so
i'll walk with you as you learn these
skills that you've yet to learn but
until you learn them i'm not going to be
able to leave you anything
you're opting out you're choosing
by your misbehavior to not be in the
will
which i agree with it's unfortunate it's
not my child
i guess the heart strings are pulling a
little bit because
he's
has some severe health issues and will
need
some good insurance
and once his parents child is not going
to get he's like
this is a nephew
my nephew and his his parents are just
as irresponsible as him financially how
old is he
22. okay have you taken him out and
y'all two just talked for a while
oh
tried let me put it that way okay
what does that sound like
well when you've got the parents on the
other i mean they'll agree with
everything you say but when you got the
parents on the other end just uh you
know handing handing cash if it grows on
trees
that
it's a hard hard battle to win who's
convinced you that this is your problem
to solve
why have you taken this on
you've inserted yourself you've inserted
yourself into their family do you feel
guilty that you've been you've you've
made a lot of money
no not at all okay
something about the situation you've
inserted yourself into your brother or
your sister's family and taking it upon
yourself that it's your responsibility
to save their errant child
i want to free you from that man yeah
it's not your it's not on your list of
things to do
uh you know what i would do if it was my
nephew and i wanted to leave him money
to help him because he has health
problems but i think he has bigger
problems and health problems
i think he's got character issues that
supersede his health problems and may
actually add to them i don't know what
his health problems are but may make
them worse or aggravate or exasperate
the situation or whatever it is but i'm
just going to sit down with him and go
hey i'm your old ugly rich uncle you
ever heard the parable the rich uncle
i'm him i'm the guy you know that's me
and so yo everybody wants one well you
got one
and so uh if you want i i would i would
love to be a blessing in your life but i
cannot do that until you learn to behave
with money if you'll walk along this if
you let me walk along beside you i'll
kick your little butt and i will hug you
into learning how to do this life thing
and money thing right
but if you don't
not say it i'm not care about what you
say if you don't do it
then i can't leave you
money in the will
but i'd like to i'd like to be the guy
that coaches you up and takes you
through this and puts you in financial
peace university and you and i talk
about it and i see the fruit in your
life but you being in the will is
dependent on that you can opt out of
this by your behavior you can opt into
this with your behavior it'll be your
choice